all right so I'm I'm by heart and I'm
here with Sal Khan and hello yeah we're
talking about just how we think about
numbers and what what is the most
natural way to think about them in our
everyday lives and vie said that she was
way to test me right now yeah all right
can I can i yes yes I get to use the
official Penance po8
no that's all scream yes I need it you
need training by training looks like a
pizza it's it's a triangle okay where's
where's your testify okay you're
diverging I'm sorry
all right so here's the number line uh
regular old numbered line that way I
want to start at one all right we're
interested in one I'm gonna go all the
way to a million and I'm gonna give you
the pen now and I'm gonna ask where is
1,000 where is 1,000 where's 1,000 I see
I see what you're doing so you can see
yes yes so I'll tell you what went
through my mint through my brain my
first knee-jerk reaction was to put 1000
was to put 1,000 like right over here
that's that's what I was tempted to do
and then my brain kicked in my highly
analytical mind yeah she's you know
there there is a correct answer to this
problem we can think right because oh
yeah yeah where where is 1000 on the
number line related to a million well a
million divided by a thousand is a
thousand thousands right so it's not
there I was gonna draw it like a tenth
of the way no a thousand a thousand is
like like a dare like alt like you know
you would you barely notice a different
I didn't even see the difference yes I
wasn't let me let me so so this this is
fascinating what what is what is this
about like what why did I why did I do
that yeah why why do we think of a
thousands as being much closer to a
million than it is and we do this
actually all the time we're not so used
to having to think about the difference
between a thousand and a million but
when we're thinking about the difference
between 1 and 2 or the difference
between 2 and 3 or 1 and 10
um we we think you know 1 & 2 there's a
big difference there two is like twice
what yes
it's twice 1 right and the difference
between 9 and 10 is the same distance
when you're looking at it at the usual
scale it's 1 right right but when we're
thinking about real-life things well the
difference between 9 and 10 isn't so big
in any real-life situation no but but
the different 1 & 2 is huge
I realize it's double yes right so now
we have to think on a logarithmic scale
is what it is oh yes the old logarithmic
scale so what you're saying is that we
we as humans even though everything
we're taught is these linear scales
where we want to say you know this is 1
and that maybe this is 10 and that this
is 20 even though that's where we're
taught and that's where most of our
mathematics we plot lines and that's how
we draw it out on paper usually yes um
but that doesn't make sense usually for
for how we think about things because
the difference between 5 gazillion and 5
gazillion and 10 is is nothing nothing
nothing between 1 and 10 is huge right
right right so that's why almost the
multiple matters more than the the kind
of apps of the distance between the
numbers yeah absolutely and that's what
the logarithmic scale captures it is and
that's why we see the logarithmic scale
and so many things in real life as a
mathematician on the piano well we see
it on it's actually the logarithmic
scale so let's get our piano picture oh
look at that there's a piano yeah okay
okay there you go yes right let's see if
I can figure this out right so here we
have this C let's call it middle C and
here we have this D and you know there's
a certain distance between these and
then here's this C in this day and right
when we're listening to these notes we
think all right they're OneNote apart
this is like the same distance here
between here and here and here and there
but if you look at the actual
frequencies the distances are not the
same it's it's there's maybe a bad
example because I don't know the
frequency of day but no well we could
well I'll give you an example I can give
numbers too which is maybe the
difference between this octave and the
difference between this octave right
if this is C called X where the
frequency is right yes like a 440 killer
I know for a is for four days
well we call I like say 300 yes all
right so this is three hundred or 300 X
or just X then this frequency would be
600 600 right it doubles it doubles when
you when you go up an octave and this
would be 1,200 up here this C um alright
we're we're in a weird scale here but
alright so the difference between here
is 300 and the difference between here
it's 600 but you know when we're
listening to octaves we feel like the
difference between this octave shouldn't
be half as much as a difference between
these two notes right the distance from
an octave should be an octave right
right so our sense of pitch is
fundamentally the way we perceive pitch
is logarithmic it's fundamentally
logarithmic if you want all these what
if you want to have all your notes on
the piano be right next to each other
instead of having a piano where you have
like one key for C here and one key for
C here and the next C is going to be
like twice as far yeah and the next and
the piano would have to be like so if
piano manufacturers made it so they day
and they innately made it based on a
logarithmic scale whether they knew it
or not they could have made it on a
linear scale and then the keys would
just get fatter and fatter as we went to
the right oh yeah fatter keys someone
should make that a linear scale piano
yes that would be awesome and that's but
that's not how we do it it might be hard
to play to play that listen and it's not
it's not and it's just not pitch it
would also even be how we perceive a
kind of magnitude of the frequencies
because we have the decibel scale which
is a logarithmic scale yeah yeah there's
a lot of natural intuitive logarithmic
scale so when we're looking at how loud
something is as also alright the
difference between you know how I'm
talking now and how I'm talking if I'm a
little louder and that's going to be we
feel like distances between loudness
also are right we perceive it a lot it
is harder to leave it there I don't know
and we don't wanna bother people like
it's getting ice cream yes yes very
great yeah right know that that's
fascinated us little game here that I
mean this this is I'm gonna start doing
this at the next party go to you it's
good and it makes sense when we're
looking at things a difference between
how much a million dollars and ten
million dollars yes just the world
follows these kind of rules right right
right
very cool yeah awesome